alors pour clore le dossier de la
sécurité sociale commentaire d'un homme
qui fut chargé en 1945 par le
gouvernement de la libération du général
de gaulle de créer la sécurité sociale
qu'il a ensuite dirigé jusqu'en 1951
pierre laroque qui explique à daniel
leconte
quels sont pour lui les réussites et les
échecs de la sécurité sociale la
sécurité sociale a connu des succès et
des échecs succès indiscutable
l'établissement d'un sentiment de
sécurité dans la masse de la population
et particulièrement dans les éléments
qui étaient en état d'infériorité
à cet égard c'est une véritable
transformation sociale deuxième succès
l'amélioration de la santé qui est qui
est spectaculaire et les progrès
médicaux qui ont été réalisés depuis
cette époque n'aurait pas pu être
généralisé s'il n'y avait pas eu la
sécurité sociale
succès aussi par le relèvement au
traitement de la natalité succès sur le
plan économique parce que la sécurité
sociale
bien loin de gêner le redressement
économique de la période d'après guerre
la facilité et la favoriser parce que
les travailleurs qui ont travaillé en
france plus longtemps des heurts plus
longue que dans tous les autres pays
industrialisés l'ont fait dans avec le
sentiment qui travaillait pour eux il y
avait une contrepartie dans la sécurité
sociale et ça s'était établi je veux
dire c'est quelque chose indiscutable et
indiscuté résultat il ya des échecs
mieux m 2 est essentielle à mes yeux le
premier c'est que nous avons un avion
basé la sécurité sociale sur une
solidarité nationale qui existait dans
l'élan de la libération et qu'on a vue
d'assister une résurgence des
particularismes socioprofessionnelles et
à la multiplication de régimes qui ont
qui crée une très grande complication
dans l'institution et qui en diminue son
efficacité le deuxième échec c'est que
nous en nous entendions en 1945 c'était
la volonté générale responsabiliser les
bénéficiaires en leur confiant la
gestion de l'institution et en espérant
que ils se sont ils responsables de la
sécurité sociale qui sait une chose à
eux et qui ferai l'effort nécessaire
pour qu'elle fonctionne bien
cette responsabilisation nous n'avons
pas réussi et j'ai eu nouveau
reconnaître qu'aujourd'hui les assurés
sociaux entrent dans une caisse comme il
entrait dans un bureau de poste et bien
il faudrait que réagir contre cette
tendance que les assurés sociaux dans un
esprit de démocratie sociale car c'est
ça la démocratie sensations c'est que
les bénéficiaires le sens de la
responsabilité de ce qu'on fait à leur
profit il faudrait que les réformes
actuellement réalisations contribuent à
faire l'éducation de la population en ce
sens